[Music]
ha no YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 24th
episode of dirty chess tricks in this
episode I'm going to show you some of
the wonderful tricks against Yugoslavia
tag in the Sicilian from the black
respective now whether you have start
playing Sicilian or you are playing
regularly you are likely to face this
attack more frequently the beauty about
this attack is even though white doesn't
know the theory he can still get
tremendous attacking positions and
that's why it is more preferable choice
at the old level of chess now as usual
the setup I am going to recommend in
this video not only contains lots of
tricks but it also forces white to
castle on the kingside and completely
give up his attacking motives the
opening arises after the move Knight to
f3 and Here I am recommending exited
dragon water that is Knight to c6 main
line continues with the Moody for C
capped is d4 Knight capped is d4 and
black plays g6 in this position if white
wishes then he can play the most c4 and
enter into the more oxy bind structure
but we are looking at Yugoslavia tech
proper which continue with the move
Knight to c3 okay Bishop to g7 attacking
the knight Bishop to e3 defending the
knight and now the move Knight to f6 now
those of you who doesn't know what
exactly the Yugoslav attack is here I
have highlighted by the arrows simple
and very devastating Yugoslav attack
plan so what generally white wants to do
is he wants to play the move f3
combining with the
Bishop to c4 and then Queen to d2 castle
on the Queen side and then launched a
furious attack on the black Kings side
with the MU h4 and g4 and it is very
reliable and easy to play weapon for the
white okay here white has to continue
with the move Bishop to c4 in order to
safeguard the d5 square
now instead of Bishop to c4 if you
operon continue with other moves such as
saf3 and after the move castle
he played Queen to d2 then black has
this amazing resource defy which not
only break up the center but give a
pleasant position to the black now just
to illustrate my point I like to show
you one of the sample line let's say
White Castle on the Queen side then
black and easily able to exchange few
pieces Knight captures Bishop captures
pawn captures Knight captures Knight
captures pawn captures Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Queen to c7 and
white is left with this horrible witness
on the e4 square so that's why at this
Junction Bishop to c4 is a very
important move well after that the main
move is castle on the Kings side but I'm
not going to recommend that move instead
of that I'm proposing a very tricky move
here that is Queen to e5 which contains
so many tricks
if white continue with his Yugoslav
attack style I like to point out over
here that the only good move here for
the white is to castle on the Kings side
which of course you go slow attack
player will doesn't like it because then
black has his usual trump with the
half-open C file so the main question
arises
what's wrong with other moose well let's
see each bite on the first move I want
to consider is Knight to b3 which is the
second most popular move apart from the
castle on the Kings side well here black
reveal has
the idea with the move Queen to b4 so
not only attacking the bishop but
there's also threat on the e4 square
many people believe that tricks and
traps only work at the lower level and
at the highest level they are completely
ineffective but this is the clear case
where I want to prove them wrong the
position we have reached arises in the
game between Hikaru Nakamura who is 2700
plus rated and Lubavitch from the black
who is also a Grandmaster and Nakamura
continued the move Bishop to d3
suspecting nothing but Lubavitch give
him this ultimate shock nightcap just
efore BAM who said 2700 doesn't fall for
the tricks well if 2700 fall for it then
any of your opponent can fall for it
after the best continuation that is
Bishop captures efore pressure capture
c3 check and after pawn captures and
Queen captures 'if oh just in the 11
moves black is a clear pawn armed and
look at White Queen side it is
completely shattered
I have include the rest of the game in
the PGM which is available in the
description so kindly go through it and
find out how black completely demolish
white from this position okay
let's consider the second move that is
f3 which looks more natural at this
position but again here black has this
wonderful move Queen to b4 attacking the
bishop and after the move Bishop to b3
black has this dazzling sac Knight
captures a4 so in most of this lines
black will become a clear upon of and
all the technical aspects are safe for
the black so for example if white take
the snide then the simplest is you
regain your piece after Bishop captures
and after Bishop captures and Queen
captures black is a clear upon up
and instead of that the tricky line goes
what happens if you open and capture the
c6 night so attacking the Queen
attacking the knight pause the video and
find out how black should continue well
I hope you find this sequence that is
Bishop captures three three check to the
King pawn captures and after Queen
captures three three it is very obvious
that white has to move the King as
Bishop to d2 will ran into the night
captures g2 if King to have fun at this
position then the simplest is you take
this mission and after pawn captures and
pawn captures black emerged with a
two-point advantage and instead of that
if white King try to run away to the e2
square then you simply take this night
and now white can't even take that night
the simple reason is after that we have
this lovely blue Bishop to g4 bow home
the queen is a goner
well White has this one trick of the
sleeve that is Bishop to d4 which at
first sight looks very threatening
because it's attacking two sports but as
happens in the most of the scenario that
takes favors the brave and here black
has this amazing saving resource ePHI
and black consolidate his extra material
the cute point behind it after Bishop
captures Queen we have night capture c3
and black regain his queen with extra
pawn okay let's consider the third reply
that is Queen to d2
well after that no prize for guessing
Plex next reply it's very obvious yup
Knight captures efore with once again
the similar motifs if I capture this
night then the simplest is you take the
screen and no matter however black
let's say Bishop captures and now you
regain your peace with a clear point
advantage so that's not good for the
white and instead of night captures
efore if you open in place Knight
captures c6 then pause the video and
find out blacks mixed reply well there's
only one more in the position which
gives black advantage and that is the
stunning blue Queen captures c3 so black
regain his piece and as for the best
reply that is Queen captures Bishop
captures check and after pawn captures
and pawn captures night
once again black emerge with an extra
pawn and white has some shattered bones
on the Queen side last but not least
what happens if you open and place Queen
to d3 well this is simplest of all you
can simply play Knight to e5 attacking
to sports and after Queen d2 we can
simply take this pawn and remain a clear
pawn up
so considering all this it is very
obvious that at this point white has to
castle on the kingside and in that case
he has to give up his Yugoslav satyr and
play a different ballgame which he may
or may not be comfortable I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful tricky
set up against a Yugoslav attack thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on this video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
that black doesn't actually have to get
the position he got after move 25 and
there are ways to improve along the way
and some of those that's interesting no
he's obviously not sleeping but well a
bit strange no I mean it's it's ok but
now at this position White has this
wonderful new rope to even which create
a such a nasty trick that no matter of
black replies for example the most
frequent replies over here are Bishop to
e7 or Bishop to d7 but they all leads
disaster to the black unbelievable right
but it's true